welcome to this video this is a tactics
trainer video again let's see I said it
to something difficult I wanted a
challenge and I didn't do too well when
I tried the trainer recently in mind
they're just doing it on my own without
recording and yeah I figured let's set
it to a very high rating level and see
what happens
I put it to 2600 which does not really
relate to feeder rating but still it
should be pretty pretty tough let's see
um we're black iam time on one minute
something ok but I haven't really looked
at much yet um what kind of position do
we have young black is a pull-up
ok I'm winning the endgame probably not
we should find a tactic and the first
quite obvious ADM is the check on f3
Knight a3 check if King edge one Queen
edge to mate if why it takes it with the
pawn there's queen g3 check then King
edge one Bishop takes a three wins huge
material we are not a pawn up by the way
we are looked down I just saw that
there's a rook missing somehow so I'm
sorry for that so we need to do a little
bit more than just winning back some
material maybe hmm still neither of
three looks kind of normal Knight f3 GF
Queen g3 Czech Bishop g2 and rook t2 and
made on g2 so it looks really good
I just wonder if we play Knight f6 Oh
knight Knight f3 check King f2 is some
some sort of defense it looks it doesn't
good quindi forecheck kingi - Wendy -
322 mate 24 check King g3 Queen h4
checkmate
so after neither three has to take it if
he takes it with the Queen we take with
the bishop
I guess pawn takes Queen g3 is still
going to win with route eg to come so
let's say the check Queen takes Bishop
takes Bishop d3 check King h8 if he then
takes and checking on g3 wins f3 h3
always check at our look enter so this
wins we just try to be try to be a
little bit circumspect not putting it on
the board so quickly yeah not sure this
is wasn't so difficult but should look
at all the possible possible lines okay
the next one okay that's kind of curious
so we are we in an endgame position like
he's a click with the piece up I guess
there is some some sort of tactical idea
to win the Queen but how how exactly is
this possible him
move like Bishop h7 for example has a
couple of winning lines King F for Queen
G's remade for example or King FIF Queen
III winning he can go after Bishop age
seven he can go to d4 however after
which I don't yet see a win Queen B for
trick maybe Queen B for check he cannot
go to the e-file I a this wins yeah this
is winning honey okay check Queen B for
check is strong oh wait wandering Queen
B for check he cannot go to the e-file
he has to go to d5 I was hallucinating a
little bit him but maybe it still no I
can do that I can do what I wanted to do
sorry of course
here King D 5 Bishop G idea I forgot
about this I had seen this earlier
actually but I forgot about it
Queen takes 23 check now winning the
Queen on king c6 that was Queen a fun so
it was a really a tactical solution to
this the end game and game problem yeah
if we go back quickly here the key move
Bishop g8 if Kings is 6 then Queen a for
King c6 Queen f4 and we win the Queen
anyway and he couldn't go to the ephah
to e5 or you want you to Queen e1 check
so you have to see all those geometrical
motifs here the Queen being the strong
piece that it is ok next one we are
playing black ok
yeah this must be about e to see 3
Alice's can have a typical dragon type
of position hmm
yeah rooks III looks very obvious the
question is is there is there some
problem with it that I don't see okay
okay okay okay
there are actually more than one
possible way to do it you can think of
Bishop d4 here let's say Bishop g4 Queen
D for rooks III after BC or Queen c3
this nighty to winning but Bishop g4 24
rocks III Queen takes d4 it's a green
text f1 it's not that obviously clear to
me I mean I don't see direct win then
sacrifices probably don't work this also
rook takes c3 which is quite interesting
look take c3b takes we take on a three
and then we are going to checkmate with
Queen a to check when a one mate Roxy
three bishop c3 there is Bishop takes
you three BC again Queen a three Queen
c3 Knight xe2 but there's always f4
hanging which is the annoying thing here
in this disposition
there's always this this pawn this night
hanging is there some way around that
like oopsie three Queen f4 is there some
got some some strong their roots III
bishops III Bishop takes c3 Queen takes
f4 is also not not really clear at all
so hmm is it something else maybe
something totally totally different I
mean is likely let's say Bishop h6
intending 92 winning the Queen not not
totally totally ridiculous but it feels
there should be something something
stronger Bishop c4 Queen D form assume
and absolutely
German German everything creeping into
my mind Bishop T for Queen D for Queen
takes c3 this is possible let's check
this Bishop before Queen f4 we take c3
Alice's 23 BC 92 with a good piece yeah
that seems to win Luke takes this Queen
fo but I can take with the Queen and
after B takes Knight takes it to an I'm
having an extra piece at the end yeah
this is this is an extra piece for black
yeah took a while but I spotted it okay
next one
wow this really looks a lot there there
should be some some sort of meteorite
but why does I mean why does not have
many pieces left that's quite often a
problem if you don't have any pieces to
finally checkmate
okay the first thing or the first move
coming to mind is Queen f6 I think black
really has only one check like Queen d2
and this is just one check so we need a
mating a mating net somehow not a Queen
f6 friends Queen ecigs with a checkmate
to come and Queen takes h8 if he takes
Knight xe5 queen is seven mate and if he
takes with the pawn queen is six check
and made on d7 I don't think there is a
defense to that it can only give this
this one check so I'm not quite sure why
this is so hydrated this problem maybe
it's someone some problem that wasn't
tried that much this was relatively
relatively easy okay the next one and
game night endgame versus this is an
especially calculation heavy those a
knight end game okay third thing that
comes to my mind is that there are
mating ideas here like King on before
night c5 made not sure how relevant it
is but it is something to keep in mind
the other thing that comes to
consideration of course is that we have
the H pond which can be very very
dangerous f6 would be something to
consider
first and foremost f6 pawn takes on f6
it's probably the only move h5
twin g3 sorry night xg3
age six Knight e4 and but like just
about saves it with 96 night f7
hmm tricky
96
I wonder if I can somehow I think I need
to combine the ideas with the this
breakthrough and and the made but how
exactly
Shampoo there's really only one solution
to that that's hard to believe
really that's hard to believe that you
cannot somehow interchange move or the
CM a what f6 is the most obvious way to
do it I think that King B form and 96
threatening this mate is the is the
point so that when the knight returns to
you for we actually can play Knight c5
check with the trade but I'm not totally
convinced about what move orders right
okay I'm going for that now I don't want
to spend have a now on the most precise
solution so H 593 aged 694 and now he's
four in for Knight to d6 if I play King
before then 96 96 King ma'am that's not
working
King King me seven kiddo the knight 98
check and then it's promoting so let's
do that age six has to go night if four
and that's the same thing
the ideas 96 to 207 to stop it so oh
it's there can I can I allow him to go
in there
oh yeah I can I can actually so age
seven yeah I saw the right ideas but
it's a matter of execution so here and
now 96 is the key move 95 made
threatened and on king b7 I have this
check to get to distract the night so
promoting yeah they have to combine
those ideas correctly and I wasn't
totally sure when I started to enter the
Moose what the correct move are is okay
so the next one again I look super
critical huh okay night at seven shaking
g8 98 98 check Bishop takes is 6
hmm creamy six
what is Knight f5 just Knight f5 what is
what is the defense against that Knight
f5 for Queen g7 made you can give this
check I go to h2 and black only has
really this one check if he plays Knight
f5 rook to g8 I just take an overtake g8
if we can take a fire but I can take g7
I can take g7 97 for for the discovered
check it's really nothing you can do
against that I think hmm Knight f5 look
g8 know it takes g7 Queen b1 check or
the move before it doesn't matter really
uncheck King edge to the threatening
Knight f5 with the maiden at age 5 with
her maid and from b1 enough this is
winning this is winning if not only only
this one really only this move now he
should have continued that rook G idea
rook g8 97 group g7 Queen evade with the
win and 97 he can only give check out b1
King edge to rook takes you seven again
Queen evade mate so not not so difficult
okay the next one nice attacking
position but how exactly are we winning
yeah the bishop to c2 at some point
looks like a key idea also nygean
tending Queen h6 is an important motif
there is not that's not yet something
like win takes h6 this is a little bit a
little bit too much what about rook h3
it's hard to believe that there is only
one win in this position really this is
like so much over the teching force here
combined against blacks King h3 is
simply winning what what is the point
bishop moves mated Knight moves unmated
he can really only play rook age 8 and
then there's Queen takes f7 made what is
the big deal yeah I don't get it Luke h3
looks like a super simple win yeah how
much to do it is the winner yes Queen
takes h6 yeah no we are going to made it
sometimes we area those ranks
1000 attempts were made 1100 and only 50
percent pass rate okay
it's a very very strong attacking
position where probably this more than
one good continuation can easily be
tempted by something else but this was
quite quite clear with regret three
okay so the next one I am going for
black f3 being played Wow huh
again it looks like a very strong
attacking position most obvious moves
being Queen D 323 King F - mm-hmm
one thing that I'm thinking about that
there might be something with there
might be something with Bishop h3 at age
4 at some point at the moment this is
blocked with the rook hmm yeah Queen d3
is some very very tempting if he goes to
e1 this route g2 mating
hmm okay but we need three king f2 as
some the more problematic move anyway
hmm can't agency if I was cheeky King
takes and then what exactly don't see it
I don't see it
okay one move also possible here is e
forward some some stage like Queen D 3
check King F to e 4 we can take with the
night on your form and I have no obvious
continuation yeah that looks it looks
terribly dangerous but I haven't seen I
haven't seen it yet
I really haven't Queen D 3 king of to e4
Knight takes not really leading to
anything
also and this idea to somehow play queen
e6h 3 this is attacking this attacking
roots also making lots of sense
yeah my technical shortcomings I don't
really I don't really see a quick win
maybe it's very easy maybe it is the
other candidate moves
besides Quinn d3 yeah move like we need
six I don't believe it even if I get a
check-in on age three King he - and he's
running all the way to d3 clearly three
looks perfectly normal come on let's do
that I am this is a little bit of a
gamble and Here I am it would be really
nice if I get in the Bishop h4 is made
yeah if it could jump over the rook it's
a very very simple type of check made
Queen III would also also be quite
obviously nice but I don't see how we
get rid of the bishop on e4 I thought
Knight takes d4 and I really don't see
the big point of the whole operation
is there any way forward I can what if I
take on c5 Queen takes Queen takes then
you fall no matter always Quincy
forecheck as well
I don't see it I'm sorry what can I do
me I simply don't see it if somehow we
for looks looks right but night takes
before after that I really don't see a
solution here I don't see it I simply
don't eat for night chicks
what about now briefly thinking Bishop D
aid but Queen d6 is coming if you take
on c5 green checks is there some way to
get the Queen away from ya there's
always Quincy form check
oh yeah I mean this is smooth Bishop h4
is really nice can we wait if I just
play if I just play the move like is it
mattering rook g6 intending Bishop h4
made and if he if he then decides to
take on on on e7 then I play Queen e3
and checkmate him that's actually really
nice isn't this g6
yes I got it I mean I mean I took me
ages and and but yeah I don't know yeah
this is kind of silent moves they are is
so bad it was bad right I saw this
Bishop h4 mate idea so I should have
looked at rook g6 much earlier and then
maybe as I would have spotted it it's
really a kind of an overload of the c5
bishop it has to protect III and and
look at the seven bishop so I don't know
why it was so so long that I took I mean
besides my technical shortcomings but
still I should have seen it a little bit
quicker okay the next one and the final
one for the session okay this really
this is a technical problem Wow
it doesn't look like it should be any
problem but maybe it is if we go Queen
to G
when g8 King f6 Queen g7 made Queen g8
checked into each zone g7 check King f6
it feels like there should be some some
funny made here like in Java is called
epaulette much a poorly made or
something hmm
it could be something like this in this
position but okay um I was looking at
yeah rook g7 of g7 King and King f6
Queen h6 King f5
I'm running all the way Wow
King f5 Queen h7 chick as a jig on F on
f4
hmm
hmm and the promise and the king is on
there for this the King movies was check
actually that's quite quite quite
difficult to meet hmm Wow
you have so many chicks yet so it's
actually kind of kind of dazzling I also
wonder what Quincy area Queen g8 King is
7 rock g7 check
I wear this they don't have seven what
exactly is the problem here I don't have
seven yeah it just it's just a made on
f7 I mean I don't know it's because it's
so many chicks yeah I was really kind of
kind of thinking I must be something
difficult you have the King running
around or whatnot and it's just those
two chicks yeah King to f6 is actually
made with rook f7 or Kamino sir not that
not that difficult there are many
problems in the selling where didn't
really know why the problem rating is
that time it's a mathematical
calculation so for some reason people
seem to fail this a lot okay I hope you
enjoyed this session here with the
technics trainer and I will egg soon
with other instructive videos thanks for
watching